So now my goal is to start
thinking about how we going to
warp an image to a different size.
This is a global transformation, or
a global warping, and to help us,
we will need to start looking at if we
can come up with a set of parameters
that on easy adjustment
of these parameters.
We can basically take
a set of equations and
generate a new output
from a given input.
So now we want to actually start looking
at how to get an output image G if
the F is given and we have a certain set
of parameters to do this transformation.
To help us, let's create just
a simple coordinate axis here.
Usually if you remember I always put
the coordinates axis going down in y and
x this way.
Just for simplicity and consistency.
I'm going to start using
the traditional set of axis here.
Of course this would be the x-axis,
the y-axis, and this would be the (o,o).
All right?
Let's find another coordinate frame.
And here, so
assuming this is again the (o,o) and
this is x and y, you notice this
image has been moved a little bit.
Let's claim that this
has been translated.
By tx, and ty.
The translation's in x and y.
So this in essence kind of says,
that now I've translated the image.
So this is basically, warping, or
transformation of translation.
Another similar example would be when
I actually take the image, again,
the x and y axis,
that we've been paying attention to.
Origin except that now we notice.
This image has been rotated.
And if you draw this axis here,
you might say that this has
been rotated by amount theta.
And that's rotation actually now means
that basically the same pixel values
that I have here, now appear in a
different setup, and of course, thinking
hard about it, you might also thinking,
this is basically, change the way.
Rows and columns look, and
how my pixel values are looking.
So this is basically looking
at simple rotations.
Let's look at a few additional examples
of this kind of, parametric warping or
transformation of images.
Again, my input image.
In this one I've stretched the image.
Right.
In essence,
what I've done is I've scaled it.
I've added basic additional
dimension in the.
X axis then I have here,
y in this one is of course the same.
Result in of course my vit is larger and
in this case the height is the same.
This basically where we just
change one scale parameter is
the change of the aspect of the image,
and of course we could do this in both
directions x and y, and of course that's
the change in the scale of the image.
Very simple stuff so far.
Another example where
a basically have the same image.
So this time around if you
notice that we've actually done
an interesting thing.
What we've done here is,
we've added a little bit of
perspective projector warp.
Now the top row is much top numbers or
top part is much smaller.
Bottom is larger, and
in essence, the image seems to have
flipped on that side a little bit.
This is, referred to as Perspective,
and this, of course,
is an example where we have created
an affine deformation of the image,
where basically now, the image seems
to have, kind of have a lot more sheer.
Again different types of warps
are transformation applied
to the same pixel values.
And of course as you noticed the domain,
the number, how the x and
y's change depend on how,
what kind of function we could apply.
So let's now talk about what kind
of functions we could apply.